il nous avait donné rendez vous ici dans
la montagne
dans cette ferme du jura vaudois on
savait qu olivier grandjean était un
ancien banquier mais aussi un campano
file réputé et on n'a pas tardé à
comprendre ce que ce terme signifier
c'est une passion je sais pas je sais
pas d'où ça vient c'est génétique
j'entends sonné une cloche j'arrête de
réfléchir j'arrête de penser et depuis
tout petit les cloches ont marqué tout
pendant offensant passage de troupeaux
fallait que j'aille écouter écouter les
cloches comparé fait écouter celle que
les copains de mon âge avait celle que
j'avais et c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé la collection si nous sommes
allés voir olivier c'était bien sûr pour
faire sonner quelques cloches mais aussi
pour découvrir romainmôtier
nichée dans un vallon un peu plus bas à
près de 700 mètres d'altitude
voici l'un des plus beaux villages de
suisse avec ses vieilles bâtisses et son
abbatiale millénaire
et c'est lui le spécialiste de la
finance le collectionneur de cloche qui
préside la fondation qui gère une partie
de ce patrimoine exceptionnel l'église
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui a
pratiquement dans sa forme du 11e siècle
il ya eu des ajouts des suppressions des
retraits des changements à passer du
roman au gothique sous l'influencé de
cluny
l'église est achevée aux mille 28 et
ensuite sous l'influencé des savoie et
suite à la réforme par les bernois ont
patiemment restauré l'abbatiale
accueille encore des cultes chaque
semaine
c'est aussi un lieu très prisé par les
organistes ici il y a même plusieurs
instruments
guy bovet est l'un des grands
spécialistes de l'orme
il a toujours été fasciné par ce site
médiéval
il ya des mystères qui attire les gens
qui en fixe quelques-uns car crash
l'autre et il ya tout le temps des
choses ici qui se passe en seulement 2
pourquoi c'est le monde commet comme la
venue de cet orgue ça reste en état par
exemple mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres
et beaucoup d'autres histoires des
maisons anciennes des gens vécu là les
gens sont morts là s'est épuisé un
endroit évidemment très calme
il ya également un autre édifice olivier
grandjean souhaitait nous faire
découvrir l'étonnante maison du prieur
qui date du xiiie siècle et qui est très
bien conservé mais attention
romainmôtier ne veux pas être un musée
mais un lieu de vie avec son salon de
thé associatif et ses résidences
d'artistes
un lieu qui est propice à la
déambulation à la réflexion et
l'imagination si à chaque fois un
nouveau détail à découvrir chacun des
bâtiments a sa propre histoire et
ensuite n'importe quelle fenêtre
n'importe quelle pierre de taille
comporte une autre histoire donc très
important de venir s'y ressourcer
et il n'y a aucun droit d'entrée pour
profiter de la beauté de romainmôtier le
site de l'abbatiale est ouvert tous les
jours de la semaine l'hiver comme l'été
[Musique]